is a survivor of the war that's ravaged
south sudan for years
displaced many times during the conflict
she now lives with her husband and four
members of their extended family
in an informal settlement in bible town
in the volatile jungle region
they receive some food from charities
and supplement that with vegetables from
a small garden
they tend near their makeshift shelter
our enemies are always attacking us we
have really suffered a lot we're always
on the run
they kidnap our people mostly women and
children now our area is empty
we lost our food during the floods now
we face hunger
i hope this war stops and we are able to
go back to normal life
but hunger is a global problem and it's
growing every year
a new report on food security provides
grim reading
150 million people in 55 countries are
in crisis say the authors
the un's world food program and the food
and agriculture organization that's an
increase of around 20 million people
from 2019
133 000 people in burkina faso south
sudan and yemen
are also facing a catastrophe and need
urgent action to prevent
widespread death and total collapse of
livelihoods
thousands of people also dying of hunger
in yemen south sudan and northern
nigeria
the country is highlighted by the report
as the worst affected
to avoid farming and to meet urgent food
needs the world food program says
5.5 billion dollars will be required
this year
covet 19 has also shown the ever
widening gap between the rich and the
poor
and how the most economically vulnerable
households
are those that will be the hardest hit
in the food chain
we are going to pray about the war in
the country
the hunger in the country the food
crisis is getting worse
we pray to god to bring these to an end
and then we have climate change in
sub-saharan africa
where most of the world's food insecure
live the situation is only getting worse
punishing countries that did little to
cause the problem
here they don't speculate about the
crisis they're suffering because of
it once proud farmers and hiders
have now been reduced to depending on
foreign aid
muhammad al jazeera